If you were the main protagonist of one piece,
what are the 3 best devil fruits you needed
to change the world?
And I mean from start to finish.
Not only defeating Black beard and the world
government, but turning the world into a better
place for everyone?
This is how you do it.
What is the most powerful devil fruit there
is?
That's a question that has been asked by a
lot of people, and the answer usually is some
variation of a top 10 list, that contains
pretty much the same fruits every time with
an unexpected fruit thrown in there for some
novelty.
I'm honestly a bit tired of the format.
And yes you clicked on my thumbnail, cause
it's a pretty good one, but you probably are
dreading the same repetitive video as well.
So for the sake of all our sanities, instead
of looking at individual fruits and giving
my opinion on how much boom boom each of these
does, I want to look at devil fruits from
a perspective I've always found leagues more
fascinating to think about anyway: What are
the best devil fruits, when they have the
chance to be used together in a strategic
way to achieve a greater goal?
And I'm not only talking about battle here,
I think very different devil fruits become
incredibly powerful depending on the context
you want to use them in.
And I thought to myself: How could I change
the world faster than Luffy?
What would I need to do?
So, I sat down with pen and paper and a big
can of coffee and started brainstorming.
And in the end, I managed to worked out 5
foolproof steps in which the right combination
of devil fruits will be an absolute game changer.
And to make it more interesting, since devil
fruits are hard to come by, I will limit myself
to 3 devil fruits per step.
Okay so close your eyes for a second.
I want you to imagine that you are the protagonist
of One Piece, you have all the knowledge about
this world, that you currently have and it's
your destiny to save this world and lead it
into a better future.
You and a handful of Nakama.
What do you have to do?
The goal will be to take down the world government,
defeat Blackbeard and create a peaceful and
prosperous world.
Well first of all, there is the issue that
we need to get our hands on the devil fruits
we need and the poneglyphs on top to find
laugh tale.
The first of our five categories therefore
will be a science slash information gathering
squad.
The best devil fruit to start out with here
I think is viola's Giro Giro no mi, hat allows
the user to see through everything.
With this, we can look anywhere for anything
we want.
Check if there is a devil fruit on board of
that ship over there?
No problem.
Check if there is a treasure at the bottom
of the sea here?
No problem.
Or even check if there is a poneglyph around
somewhere.
You could also use it to scout, to spy and
to avoid traps of any sort.
Oh and did I mention that it can read minds?
With this fruit you can locate all resources
you will need on this journey.
Money, Devil fruits, Information.
Anything.
The only problem is that you might not be
able to do much about it, even if you found
a lot of things.
This is where the other two fruits come in.
The OP Op no mi, quite well-named I have to
admit, as well as mont dor's Boku Boku no
mi.
This devil fruit not only comes with it's
own little pocket dimension, but you can also
store anything and everything inside books.
Including living things.
So all the treasure and resources you find
could be stored inside inside books without
having to worry about ever running out of
space.
Plus you can even use this ability to build
a communication network.
All this is then perfected by the OP Op no
mI's room ability, that allows you to simply
switch out the item you want and directly
store it in a book.
So you could scout a Devil fruit in a chest
on a marine ship and simply use the op op
no mi to transport it right onto your ship
Without the marines ever suspecting anything
from another ship far in the distance.
So this step is our ultimate base on which
we can build now.
You have free access to all information and
resources you could ever want.
The next thing we need is the ability to move
freely wherever we go, topple pirate crews
and corrupt governments and get rid of antagonists
that are too strong for us to face yet.
For this political slash infiltration team,
our One Piece CIA of sorts, we can first of
all reuse the OP OP no mi.
Not only can we get in and out very quickly,
but in case you've forgotten, this devil fruit
has the ability to switch personalities.
So you can easily restrict your crew member,
then change his personality with someone of
your enemies side.
With this you could infiltrate easily or if
you want to go really dark, manipulate people
to get to their devil fruits.
If you know what I mean.
As if this weren't powerful enough yet, I
would add sugars Hobby fruit as well as absaloms
Suke Suke no mi to the mix.
With that you can make a number of people
invisible to get to places unseen or simply
spy and observe.
And with sugars fruit, phew you know in a
way it's the spookiest ability in all of one
piece.
You could literally be invisible, or switch
body with king and simply touch kaido and
suddenly no-one remembers that there ever
was a YOnko named kaido.
And the toy kaido would now have to obey your
every order.
Really spooky thought, but definitely effective.
So now, we actually have the means to get
close to pretty much anyone, topple countries
and erase enemies from memory.
Even still, this might not be enough yet.
While in theory you could try and take out
Im or Blackbeard that way, we have to assume
that these groups are powerful enough themselves
to deal with such a sneak attack.
So now, that you can gather all the resources
you need, might as well go to Laugh tale,
learn the true history.
And oh boy, you cant share what was on laugh
tale, but now you're really pumped to change
the world.
So now, we're going for the big guns.
By the way, if you're enjoying this, let me
know if you'd like to see a version where
I only get to use 1 fruit in total at the
start and everything is just as in the story.
That might be fun to figure out as well.
SO make sure to subscribe for that.
Step 3: Build an army.
Now we're getting to the boom part.
And I personally think that's a lot more enjoyable
to think about now.
One thing we can do now of course is start
building an army.
Sadly, you're not Luffy and don't have his
special ability to bring people to his side.
SO we have to make due with what we have.
By liberating countries we can get their soldiers
to join us.
And by turning other pirate captains into
toys, we can then stroll by and recruit their
men to our cause.
And maybe even share some crucial information
with the revolutionaries to have them in as
well.
Maybe cause some internal conflict within
the marines too, just in case.
noice.
So now, that you have your army, the first
thing we want of course is a big boom boom
machine, and that right now to me can be none
other than Kaido's Uo Uo no mi.
If it isn't an actual ancient weapon, it might
as well be one.
I mean come on.
[] With this you can deal a lot of wide area
damage, create storms, make things float and
except to people with strong Conquerors haki
your practically invincible.
That's some great choice for some decent dps.
And compared to the gura gura no mi, you don't
risk dealing collateral damage to half your
men as well.
Looking back at Marineford, that was really
a wild ride with Whitebeards power.[]
Instead of going for more fire power here,
I would balance the Dragon with Mancheries
Heal Heal fruit, which is able to affect a
large number of people is an essential part
to stay a strong and prepared force, even
during battle, as well as with Bartolomeos
Bari Bari no mi.
That may be a bit of an odd choice, but not
only can you use it to block enemy attacks
of any sort, but you can also shield your
own army at the beginning while launching
a wide area attack.
At the same time, it can be used to make a
path for your troops up a wall or a mountain
or even shield someone until they're in the
middle of the enemy.
And of course, some of the previous devil
fruits we've gathered will be just as useful.
For example, you can use the OP OP no mi to
transport troops quickly or destroy enemy
ships.
With this absolutely ridiculous force, it
should be easy to defeat even the likes of
Blackbeard, Akainu and Imu.
Using a mix of military and political strategy
to bring down the system that has plagued
the one piece world for centuries.
Now however, it will also be your responsibility
to make sure the world becomes a better place
and doesn't sink into more chaos.
You already have the means to secure political
power for now and keep others trying to take
advantage of the situation at bay.
The best way to unite the people of the world,
is to actually have a landmass where people
can live together in piece.
After all the one pice world is 99% water.
In case you're wondering, new landmasses are
created by volcanic eruptions underwater,
like this new island that was formed just
a few years ago on the canaries.
A really spectacular and impressive process
I think.
And luckily there is a devil fruit out there
that is just perfect for this.
With the help of Akainu's Manu Manu no mi,
you could create landmasses throughout the
one piece world, connect islands and widening
existing land masses.
The poor person with that fruit would have
to work for quite a while, but maybe akainu
himself might be the right candidate to deal
with his anger issues.
Once the magma has solidified, aided by storms
created by our usefull little dragon, an incredibly
powerful fruit to have will be Pika's Ishi
Ishi no mi.
With its help, instead of getting small balls
by abusing steroids, you could actually shape
entire islands into cities with walls, buildings
and infrastructure for people to use.
Heck, you could change the geography in such
a way, to create the perfect climatic conditions
for agriculture, forming huge terraces with
rivers flowing from the mountains.
You could shield cities from floods and create
the optimal conditions for new countries to
flourish.
Honestly, this is such an overpowered and
useful fruit.
Pica and Sugar really did the worst things
possible with their abilities.
So now that we have free housing, free infrastructure
and can shape our terrain whatever way we
want, the last problem we face here, is that
everything is still very, well, no pun intended,
rocky.
Yes, volcanic grounds are fertile, but it
would take forever to get vegetation everywhere.
And so the third fruit you should use to solve
that problem is none other than Streusen's
Kiku Kiku no mi.
[] That might sound weird at first, but think
about it.
This fruit is as ridiculously op in terms
of civilisation building as it gets.
You can take infinite stone we have made with
the Magu magu fruit to turn into nutritious
food for all the people.
How crazy is that.
But even better, you could turn large chunks
of rock into vegetables and grains, and all
you have to do is take the seeds and plant
them all over the place to not only create
vegetation, but vegetation that can be turned
into food.
This is the fruit to start a flourishing economy.
And what better way to have people forget
their prejudices agains Fishman and co, if
there is enough space and food and wealth
for everyone.
Boom.
One Piece solved in 4 easy steps with less
than a dozen devil fruits.
As you can tell I'm in a devil fruit frenzy
at the moment, and if you are too and want
to know why shanks actually stole the gomu
gomu no mi, I strongly recommend you watch
that video next.